tout d'abord s'agissant du projet de loi
constitutionnelle
il conforte l'indépendance de nos
juridictions avec le renforcement des
pouvoirs du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pour la nomination et
l'exercice du pouvoir disciplinaire des
magistrats du parquet il organise
également la fin de la présence de
droits des anciens présidents de la
république au conseil constitutionnel il
modernise la procédure de mise en cause
de la responsabilité pénale des
ministres pour les faits commis dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions procédure
qui sera désormais du ressort de la cour
d'appel de paris et plus de la cour de
justice de la république laquelle sera
supprimée sur la proposition du
gouvernement et avec l'approbation de
l'ensemble des groupes parlementaires
un filtre sera toutefois conservé pour
que la responsabilité pénale des
ministres ne soit engagée qu'à bon
escient
le projet doit constitutionnel procède
également à une transformation profonde
du conseil économique social et
environnemental qui deviendra une
chambre de la société civile chargée
avec un nombre de membres réduit de
moitié d'organiser les consultations des
citoyens et des experts sur les projets
d'avenir pour notre pays